the last game but most of any tea this  year in the NBA  anytime he has to blows you you better  have your hands grip rope ad regime  defensively but they still hang their  hat on their offense Lopez away by the  Lakers and how much Gotham Utley goes  Lonzo gets stopped at the very close  pass to pay CK to shoot about the odds a  hoof pick by Lopez kick to Kuzma rain  fog for the pumps shooter steel doors  Bosh locates the break right wing Josh  Hart  Josh our levels in the half the end of  the game clock ball attached already but  it yes dirt assign mouse 18 point lead  10 minutes to play la bundle on top get  Julius Randle trying to get lines over  the tip of Gotham  does